hey guys it is monday and it's a holiday
in the u.s today but not
in australia so we're here to make sure
you know all the important gaming news
for the start of your week we sure are
here's what happened today
let's kick things off by making us all
feel old guess what came out 10 years
ago what bioshock
assassin's creed portal portal rock band
oh my god oh my god i only knew those
two and the witcher and the witcher to
celebrate that last one instead of
red have made a celebratory video the
anniversary video shows protagonist
geralt looking back on his memories as
part of a birthday party where people
are playing gwent because of course they
are the witcher 2 arrived in 2011 and
was followed up by the witcher 3 in 2015
but now it sounds like the franchise is
taking a little rest the witcher 3
wrapped up geralt's story but there
might be more games in the series
without him
setter project red ceo adam kaczynski
said it would be
unfair to fans of the series to not make
a fourth game
so chances are more witcher will be on
the horizon at some point but probably
not
anytime soon as the death are pretty
busy with cyberpunk 2077
and gwent at the moment you guys rarely
send me new stories that you think we
should cover but uh this appears to be
an exception because it sounds like a
lot of you guys know that i'm a big fan
of american begins alice
that's that's my book and uh it sounds
like he wants to make a third one
this is pretty yeah it's super pretty
interestingly just over a month ago
american insisted that he has no
authority over the future of the alice
series as ea owns and controls the ip
but it seems as if things have shifted
as he's announced plans on twitter and
his blog to pitch a proposal to ea to
create a brand new alice game
american has tentatively titled the new
game alice asylum and explained that the
proposal will include artwork
a design outline and a financial and
business model and that the plan is to
send it along to ea
if this sounds like a thing you want you
can sign up to the mailing list on
americanmighty's website to show your
support
you may remember murmurings from
microsoft that they were going to add
keyboard and mouse support to xbox one
well xbox director mike ibarra has said
that it sounds like it might be coming
here's the latest
speaking at pax west yabara said that
keyboard and mouse support is definitely
coming
and it's not something they're taking
lightly addressing the concerns some
players have that those using the new
input method will have an edge over
traditional controller players
he said we have to be very smart in how
we do that
we'll leave it a lot up to develop a
choice if you have a competitive game
people probably are going to want the
choice to say i'll play with other
keyboard and mouse people
or i'll play only with controller people
or that i'll play with any of those
he went on to say that we'll see
keyboard and mouse support in some games
soon and then support will be up to
individual developers going forward let
us know what you think of keyboard and
mouse on consoles and if you're
interested in giving this a shot
that's everything we have for you today
enjoy the rest of your day and make sure
you're subscribed to see us all the days
of the working week for all the gaming
news you'll ever need
that's right bye perfect
monday and it's a holiday in the us
today but not in australia so we're here
making sure you know all the important
gaming news for the start of the week
well we're trying to at least so here's
what we know and here's what we're about
to tell you
why would i say it like that i lit i
changed my bit so your bit would makes
it